Show Playlist
Oh
Good evening.
Hello, welcome to the table.
Glad to see all of y'all here.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
For those of you who are joining us online,
glad that you're able to log in and join us online as well.
Thanks for everybody getting in here and getting settled.
It's great to see so many faces.
It's amazing.
My name is Don Jacobs.
I'm one of the leadership team members here at the table.
Glad to see all you guys here.
And before we get started,
I do have a couple of quick announcements before we get kind of into the service
and everything like that.
Real quickly, just after the service,
we are doing a couple of different things.
One is the welcome to the table class.
That's something if you're interested in getting more involved in the table
or just wanting to learn more about what the table is about
and who we are as a community.
We're having a class right after church tonight.
So make sure you stick around and stay for that.
Even if you didn't actually register online previously,
there's still plenty of room for you there.
So that's something you're even remotely interested in.
Just stick around.
You're most definitely welcome.
The other thing is for anybody else who's interested in joining that,
you already know what everything is about the table.
We are doing our first family monthly dinner at Hat Creek.
I always have to stop and think about that one for a second.
Visit Hat Creek.
It's a great place for the kids.
There's a lot of spaces for the kids to run and do their thing.
But it's a great place to connect, to socialize,
to just kind of feel like you're just more of a table family.
So either place you go to, there's going to be food,
which is probably the most important thing, right?
Anyway, so yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
Anyway, so with all that being said,
just kind of remember that as we are getting ready.
But I'm going to pray and then we'll get started with our service.
Lord, thank you so much for bringing us all together.
Thank you for the people in this room, the people who are online,
anyone who can hear me through this microphone
and just listening through technology.
I just pray that you open our hearts, our minds.
No matter where we came from this week, whether it was a great week,
where the week was kind of stressful or we struggled through things,
I pray that you help us just be able to open
and be vulnerable, to connect, to be able to tune in
to what you have us to be here for today,
whether it's through worship, whether that is through the words
that are going to be shared by Brett,
or whether it's just some conversation that we get involved to.
I pray that you open our hearts and minds to your leading.
In Christ's name I pray, amen.
All right, you guys, if y'all would stand with us.
I'm so excited to see a lot of faces that I'm friends with
and then some faces that I may have never met before.
So just to rip off any ideas that something is different
about the people on this side of the stage
and the people on that side of the stage,
let's just take that away for a moment.
And we are just all making music together as friends in this room.
That's what we do during our worship time.
It's a creative space where all of us hopefully feel the freedom
and the room and the space to be involved at whatever level
you're comfortable being involved in.
And so I just wanted to introduce the people that are up here
and hopefully that will help kind of this weird divided wall thing
to melt away as we sing and play together
and we can just have kind of like a campfire session.
This is my sister Melody.
This is the fabulous Brock duo up here.
So this is Joe and Josh Brock.
They are a unit.
This is Jesse Watts, my good friend Jesse.
He has quite a fan club.
And my name is Mindy.
And I'm just really, thank you, sharing the love.
I'm feeling it.
But I am just really excited to be in this space together.
So we're going to jump in.
Joe's going to lead our first song.
If you know it, please sing along.
If you don't know it, please sing along.
All right, that's just how things go here.
We just jump in together.
But truly, we want you to feel the space in the room
to be as connected to this music as you possibly can be
because I feel like something creative,
something unusual happens whenever we're making music together,
whether that's with our voice or with instruments
or clapping our hands, raising our hands, whatever it is,
that space kind of engages our whole self.
So I just invite you into that space with us.
All right?
I love you, Lord.
You have delivered me.
You have delivered my soul from death, my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living, my soul from death,
my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living.
I love you, Lord.
You have delivered me.
You have delivered my soul from death, my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living, my soul from death,
my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living.
I will bless you, Lord, for you heard my cry.
I reached out my hand, and you saved my life.
I will bless you, Lord, for you heard my plea,
and the God of heaven turned His ear to me.
I will bless you, Lord, for your ending love,
for your grace and mercy rain down from above.
I will bless you, Lord, to the very end.
I will call on you as long as time may live.
And I love you, Lord, for you have delivered me.
I love you, Lord, for you have delivered my soul from death,
my feet from stumbling.
I will walk in the land of the living, my soul from death,
I will walk in the land of the living.
Yes.
Y'all sound beautiful.
Thank you, kids, for joining us for that song.
Preschool kids are going to go in this room over here,
and school-age kids, this direction.
All right?
Thank you guys so much for taking care of our kids.
We love you, kids team, so much.
All right, and we're going to transition
into the prayers of the people.
If this is your first time with us,
this is a prayer that we say together each Sunday night.
And we'll all read the prayer along together,
and then we'll leave some space for you
to offer up something that's on your heart,
whether it's someone that you're caring,
a friend that you're caring for, a family member that you're
caring for, a friend that you're caring for,
whether it's someone that you're caring,
whether it's a situation that's weighing on you tonight.
We just want to make space to hold that together up
before God, believing that he will hear that
and is also carrying it with us.
And then we'll close out with another prayer at the end.
And if you're joining us online, feel
free to leave your comments, and we
will share those with the room.
You guys read this with me.
For this city of Sachse, Texas, and for every city
and community and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth that you have given us,
and the wisdom and the will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and the orphan,
for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives and all
who remember and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their gender, sexuality, race,
or other perceived difference, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection,
and for those struggling with mental and emotional health,
we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that you hear us,
so we lift these names and situations up to you.
For the names and moments that we've spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
For the names and moments that we've spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing
and hope, peace, and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
I just want to speak the name of Jesus over every heart
and every mind, because I know there
is peace within your presence.
I speak Jesus, and I just want to speak the name of Jesus
till every dark addiction starts to break,
declaring there is hope and there is freedom.
I speak Jesus.
Your name is power.
Your name is healing.
Your name is life.
Break every stronghold.
Shine through the shadows.
Burn like a fire.
I just want to speak the name of Jesus over fear and all anxiety.
To every soul held captive by depression, I speak Jesus.
Your name is power.
Your name is healing.
Your name is life.
Break every stronghold.
Shine through the shadows.
Burn like a fire.
Your name is power.
Your name is healing.
Your name is life.
Break every stronghold.
Shine through the shadows.
Burn like a fire.
Shout Jesus from the mountains, Jesus in the streets,
Jesus in the darkness over every enemy.
Jesus for my family, I speak the holy name, Jesus.
Sing that again.
Shout Jesus from the mountains, Jesus in the streets,
Jesus in the darkness over every enemy.
Jesus for my family, I speak the holy name, Jesus.
Shout Jesus from the mountains, Jesus in the streets,
Jesus in the darkness over every enemy.
Jesus for my family, I speak the holy name, Jesus.
Jesus.
Shout Jesus from the mountains, Jesus in the streets,
Jesus in the darkness over every enemy.
Jesus for my family, I speak the holy name, Jesus.
Your name is power.
Your name is healing.
Your name is life.
Break every stronghold.
Shine through the shadows.
Burn like a fire.
Your name is power.
Your name is healing.
Your name is life.
Break every stronghold.
Shine through the shadows.
Burn like a fire.
I just want to speak the name of Jesus.
Over every heart and every mind.
I know there is peace within your presence.
I speak Jesus.
Christ is my firm foundation.
The rock on which I stand.
When everything around me is shaken.
I've never been more glad.
I put my faith in Jesus.
Because he's never let me down.
He's faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
No, he won't.
I've still got joy in chaos.
I've got peace that makes no sense.
So I won't be going under.
I'm not held by my own strength.
Because I put my life on Jesus.
Because he's never let me down.
He's faithful in every season.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
He won't fail.
Christ is my firm foundation.
The rock on which I stand.
Everything around me is shaken.
I've never been more glad.
I put my faith in Jesus.
Because he's never let me down.
He's faithful through generations.
So why would he fail now?
He won't.
He won't fail.
Rains came, wind blew.
But my house was built on you.
And I'm safe with you.
I'm gonna make it through.
Sing that again.
Rains came, wind blew.
But my house was built on you.
I'm safe with you.
I'm gonna make it through.
Rains came, wind blew.
My house was built on you.
And I'm safe with you.
I'm gonna make it through.
And I'm gonna make it through.
Cause I'm standing strong on you.
Cause my house is built on you.
And I'm gonna make it through.
Cause I'm standing strong on you.
Cause my house was built on you.
Jesus, would we build our life upon you?
Would we anchor ourselves in to your truth?
To your grace?
Your faithfulness?
Jesus, would we find you along the way?
In the good and the bad, would we find you there?
And tonight, God, where there is sadness or defeat or depression,
God, I pray that we would somehow sense your joy spilling over us.
I sense that we would feel your friendship, your closeness.
God, would you be closer than our own heartbeat?
Where there is darkness, God, would we see your light piercing through?
Steady and strong, would we trust that you will not fail us?
When the world around us fails, when we ourselves fail, God,
you are steady.
You are the center.
And you always hold.
Thank you, Jesus, for this time together.
I pray, God, that we would find you here.
Speak to us as Brett comes.
Open our ears and our hearts.
May we be in line with you.
It's in your name we pray all these things, and thank you for tonight.
Amen.
Would you guys turn to each other before you sit down and just welcome one another,
make someone feel welcomed, and then Brett will get us started on our message.
Well, grace and peace.
It is really good to be with you all, and I want to welcome all of you,
and that includes those joining us online.
I love y'all lots.
And anyone here who's new tonight, maybe your first, second, third time,
just kind of feeling it out, we're really, really glad that you're here,
and I hope you feel a sense of just welcome.
Welcome.
This is, I mean, who Jesus was, right?
Like it's probably, maybe I won't even go with probably,
the most hospitable person to ever walk the face of the earth.
Just, I mean, opening up that table for everyone, you know,
and that's who we long to be.
We're trying.
I mean, we don't.
We're not as good as Jesus at it, but we are.
We're on the path.
You know, we're learning.
So I'll just say I'm just really glad that you all are here.
So this is, let's see, we're in the season of Lent.
In the church calendar, for those unfamiliar,
this is basically kind of a 40-day season of spiritual preparation
as we approach Good Friday, that's the day of the cross,
and then on to Easter Sunday after that.
So it's not unusual to either, like, fast something during this time
or, like, engage in new practice, you know,
maybe a new spiritual discipline or something along those lines.
So at any rate, that's, you know, a number of folks are doing that.
So if you'd like to, you know, jump in, it's not too late.
Not too late.
So right here at the pretty, you know, towards the beginning of the season.
So we are, of course, we're doing kind of a sermon series in line with that.
So our series right now is titled Lent, the Way of the Cross.
And the title of my message for this second Sunday in Lent is The Descent.
The Descent.
And we're going to have just one primary passage.
This is from the book of 1 Peter 3, verses 18 through 20.
And it says this,
For Christ also suffered once for sins, the righteous for the unrighteous,
to bring you to God.
He was put to death in the body, but made alive in the spirit.
After being made alive, he went and made proclamation to the imprisoned spirits,
to those who were disobedient long ago when God waited patiently
in the days of Noah while the ark was being built.
So this is a bit of a kind of a mysterious, strange passage.
I don't know how it hits each of you.
But it's the way it's commonly interpreted,
and I'll be kind of playing off that tonight,
is as something known as the harrowing or the kind of battle,
the plundering of hell.
And, you know, of course, in Christian tradition,
Christ was crucified on Friday and then resurrected Sunday.
And so in between, there's this idea that Christ went all the way down
into what in the Old Testament is referred to as Sheol,
the place of the dead, which is actually, if you kind of read it,
it's a little bit different than hell, because it's just the place of the dead.
Like everyone kind of went there, at least that was the idea.
And it kind of morphs a little bit as you get to the New Testament,
and then you get these various terms translated in English as hell,
but like Tartarus and Hades, words like that, Gehenna.
But the idea is basically the same, that after his crucifixion,
Christ goes all the way down into that place.
And, of course, is resurrected.
So this doctrine, it was kind of formalized, though, in the Apostles' Creed,
this famous creed from very early in Christian faith, which says this,
I believe in God the Father Almighty, creator of heaven and earth.
I believe in Jesus Christ, his only Son, our Lord,
who was conceived by the Holy Spirit and born of the Virgin Mary.
He suffered under Pontius Pilate, was crucified, died, and was buried.
He descended to hell.
The third day, he rose again from the dead.
So what on earth are we to make of this?
This is sort of, I think for a number of folks,
this is sort of a somewhat obscure sort of doctrine,
maybe even a little bit of like kind of mythology and Christianity
that sort of, you know, be left to the side
and certainly not really preached on very often.
But I think that's a mistake.
I think we actually need, that there's something going on here
that's actually quite powerful.
It's not something we should let go of so easily.
And the reason why, I think, is that the language of hell,
it's very obviously super intense language,
and it certainly doesn't refer to like everything bad in human existence.
You know, not everything is hellish, so to speak.
However, like when we're trying to,
you might say it's the best language we have for the most,
like not only for kind of some sort of afterlife place,
but also for the most extreme, intense forms of human,
like evil and suffering that we undergo.
And I think that's where we can get a little bit impoverished
if we just sort of let it go.
You know, just sort of like, I don't know about all that, you know.
I think we need this.
In fact, Fleming Rutledge, I mentioned her last week,
her wonderful book, The Crucifixion.
And if you're into 600-page books of theology, that's the book for you.
But she mentions, she actually has this point
where she references an essayist named Lance Morrow,
and he points out that he says there's just a big difference,
he calls it a categorical difference, between wrong and evil.
And the way he kind of parses this is he says,
you know, when I think of like wrongs,
wrongs are things that in this life can be just set right.
You know, like you mess up, and you're like, hey, my bad.
You know, and they're like, forgiven.
It's just, you know what I mean, it's just over.
Like you ever had to get in a kind of relational spat like that?
It's just like, it's over. Like, all right, all good.
And that's, he says, Lance Morrow points out, he's like, that's wrong.
You know, something that can easily be set right.
He said, but evil, it's just more difficult.
It's not, it's not so easy.
It's like, hey, my bad, you know, my B.
And they're like, oh, don't worry about it.
You know, it's just no, no, that there's just something different, right?
Wrongs can be set right.
But there's just like one, maybe a few metaphors to think of it.
Like the difference between like having a hard day and the hell of deep depression.
You know, you're like, well, both are bad.
You know, it's like, yeah, but there's just a difference, you know,
or getting a head cold versus the hell of chronic illness or cancer.
You know, like it's just different categories.
Or again, as I mentioned earlier, like the difference between like a relational spat,
a little conflict versus the hell of chronic abuse, violence, war.
Like that, it's just, these are different levels.
They're just not really on the same plane.
But this is something I just so appreciate about Christian theology,
about Christian scriptures, about Christ himself, is that it doesn't,
they don't shy away from these more intense experiences.
Right. Doesn't kind of try to like paper over them or explain them away.
You know, no, it's like they're willing to really go all the way.
Now, it's not to say a lot of Christians aren't so willing.
Like certainly you can find plenty of, you know, somewhat shallow Facebook posts,
you know, that are like trying to kind of set like things that are evil as just merely wrong
and then like rushing people towards forgiveness.
You know, OK, so I know Christians do that.
But I'm saying Christ and the scriptures like are willing to a point that it makes us kind of uncomfortable
when we read the Bible at times like, whoa, it is willing to go there.
Right. Willing to talk about human evil and what we're like, what we're capable of,
what we experience as victims, what we perpetrate.
I mean, it's like willing to go into those places.
And so I think of this picture of Christ's descent into hell.
It's such a powerful picture of not just our hard days or our boo-boos, you know, our mistakes.
I made a mistake. No, but it's like it's a picture of him really going all the way down into human evil
and suffering into our and the world's hells.
There's a marvelous, marvelous novel by a writer named Chaim Potok.
And it's just a great story. The novel's titled My Name is Asher Lev.
And it was written quite a while ago, maybe 30, 40 years, but wonderful.
And the story is of a young Orthodox Jewish boy.
And he grows up in Brooklyn.
It's, of course, entirely fictional, but he grows up in Brooklyn.
And the crisis sort of comes about, though, in that he finds from a very young age he's obsessively drawing.
And eventually he feels this call to become an artist.
And the problem becomes that this brings him into conflict with not only his parents,
but also his religious tradition.
Because in the Old Testament, there's certain prohibitions against creating graven images.
And so in at least his kind of wing of Orthodox Judaism,
that's painting and the arts are like, no, we don't really do that.
And also time spent painting and kind of obsessing over that is less time spent studying Torah, the scripture.
And so just the whole community is just like, no, no, we don't want to do this.
But he ends up pursuing it anyway.
And he grows up and he has his first art show.
And there's one painting in particular that the Gentile, the non-Jewish art critics, rave.
I mean, they're like, this, I mean, he's only like 19 or something, but like, this is a masterpiece, like rivaling Picasso.
He's going to be the next Picasso.
Like, they're just glowing about this.
And so his parents kind of go through the art exhibit.
And then they come to this painting and they are absolutely horrified when they see that he's painted a crucifixion scene.
And if you know anything about like the history of Judaism and such, the reason this is such a big deal is because there's been so many years,
I mean, millennia of like anti-Semitism and for this very wrongheaded idea that it was the Jewish people who put Jesus on the cross,
even though the truth is and the theological truth is it was us, humanity, we put Jesus on the cross.
But this idea, you know, that that's how it played out in religious history.
And so for good reason, his parents are literally go to him and they're just like, Asher, like, why?
Why? Why a crucifixion? Like of all of the things, like the nudes we could kind of handle, you know, like we can deal like this.
Like, what are you thinking? Like, how could you do this to us, Asher? How could you do this?
And his response just struck me.
He he said this, I needed an image embedded in humanity's consciousness of God forsakenness.
I needed a picture of not just like suffering, but prolonged agony.
I needed a picture of hell.
And that's why I painted it.
And it just it seems to me that Asher Lev is absolutely right, that the descent into hell,
can you see that it's simply following the logic of the crucifixion itself?
I mean, what is the crucifixion but hell? Right.
It's just it's just following that idea and it's just playing it out.
And and it's the yeah, it's the picture where Christ goes all the way down,
down into the worst that humanity both suffers and perpetrates.
It's it's Christ descends down, down into your depression, into your grief,
into your violence, into illness, into a rejection.
Christ sinks into a pit of darkness so deep that that no light could hope to reach him.
He goes down, down, down into that place where even we begin to wonder, might God have abandoned me?
Have you ever been there in that place? Like, might God have abandoned me?
I feel so alone. What is that?
It's like a taste of hell.
And Christ goes down into that. He meets us even there.
Have you been there in that hell as a victim?
As someone who has had to live your whole life in response to what they did to you.
That thing you'll never forget.
And at times it feels like you'll never forgive them, never be capable of forgiving them.
Like they robbed you of life and light.
They robbed you like there was a time before then when you believed in the goodness of people.
And then after that, it was like before and after.
And after that, it's like you just went down.
Have you ever felt that the darkness has extinguished your light?
Friends, the gospel of Jesus Christ comes to you today.
Christ has descended into your hell.
He has found you in your depression. He has found you in your suicidal ideation.
He has found you in the midst of your abuse.
He has found you in your feelings of worthlessness.
And he has met you. He has met you in that place.
In the midst of your loss, in your grief.
But he does not stop there.
He is, according to 1 Peter 3.18, doing what?
Bringing you to God.
That's a word for someone here tonight.
He is bringing you to God.
Bringing you, each and every one of you, to God.
Christ is offering you a hand.
Not only of empathy, though it is that.
Not only of presence.
Christ being with you in the midst of the hell you have gone through or are currently going through.
Because Lord knows, some of us are going through it right now.
But it's not only empathy, though it is that.
It's more than that, though.
He is offering you a power.
And by his Holy Spirit, he is bringing you out of that pit.
Friends, I could have you speak, no matter what you're going through,
I could have you speak to half a dozen people tonight
who have been there in that thing and Christ has brought them out.
Christ loves you with a furious and a passionate love.
Christ is fighting for you.
Have you been there?
In hell?
As a perpetrator?
This one's harder.
Have you felt there's no forgiveness of sins for you?
Because what you did, it wasn't like just wrong, the mistake.
It wasn't just wrong that could easily be set right.
It was something else.
It was sin.
It was evil. It was hurtful.
Have you felt in your bones that if people knew what you had done, they would reject you?
And that's why you just keep it, just buried.
Just buried.
Maybe even go to a meetup or small group where you're like,
we're not going there.
We're just not going there.
Have you been there in that hell?
Are you there now?
The gospel of Jesus Christ sounds in your ears.
Verse 18,
Christ also suffered once for sins,
the righteous for the unrighteous,
to bring you to God.
Yes, you were, pick your metaphor,
unrighteous, unclean, prone to every form of evil,
but Christ, the righteous one, the innocent one, has died on your behalf.
He's gone to the depths of the hell that you've made.
The depths of the hell perhaps that you even plunged others into.
But he now offers you forgiveness of sins and a new life.
See, Christ has harrowed, has fought, has overcome hell.
Christ has gone down into the depths of your sheol.
Christ too has been abused and violated and ashamed.
Christ went all the way down into death,
but he did not stay there.
There is a greater power than the power of the devil.
There is a greater power than the power of hell.
There is a greater power than the power of your depression
or your abuse or your rejection
by people you loved, church leaders, pastors, friends, family.
There is a greater power than that.
Christ is the greater power and he is now trampling hell
and he is leading you and all people out.
You see, since Christ descended into hell,
that means no one is beyond his reach.
No one is beyond his reach.
You are not beyond his reach.
I've often wondered about Judas Iscariot.
He, of course, the infamous disciple
who betrayed Jesus for 30 pieces of silver.
I've wondered what went through his mind.
There's even the details of the story and how it all happened.
You remember he was going to lead a mob of soldiers to Christ
and they didn't exactly know which of the 12,
or I guess 13, well, 12 because Judas isn't in the group,
which ones Christ.
You remember how he was going to single Jesus out,
the one that they should arrest.
You remember what it was?
Kiss on the cheek.
Like in that culture, this kind of picture of friendship and connection.
And he does it.
Walks right up.
For 30 pieces of silver.
Christ, of course, is arrested, condemned to die,
and then it all hits Judas at some point.
It all hits him.
And he is undone.
You remember he goes back to the religious leaders.
You remember what he does?
He tries to give back the money.
It's a lot of money in that culture.
Tries to give it back.
You can see in that moment, what's he doing?
He's trying to distance himself from what he's done.
Like trying to make right what he cannot make right.
But he's trying.
I've been there.
Trying.
It won't work, but you try.
And he actually tells them, he says,
I've betrayed innocent blood.
That's his statement.
And then soon after that, he, of course, despairs.
Right?
No forgiveness of sins for him, his mind.
And so, of course, he ends up committing suicide that night.
So sometimes I like to imagine, though,
what if Judas did not despair?
What if he did not count himself among those
who could not be forgiven?
What if he didn't see himself as someone so far gone
that the love of God could not find him?
I like to imagine what the resurrected Jesus
might have said to him.
Like maybe a word of forgiveness.
Maybe a word of healing.
Or maybe he did.
Maybe down there in those shadowy depths of Sheol,
maybe Christ did speak to Judas.
Maybe he did forgive.
Maybe even brought him out, just like Christ does,
each and every single one of us.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So as we come to the table of the Lord tonight,
I know that was really intense.
It's Lent.
As we come to the table of the Lord tonight,
we do it as the people being brought out.
As we take in the body of Christ in the bread,
the blood of Christ in the wine,
it's this moment of connection,
it's this moment of presence,
where Christ is present to us
in the midst of whatever hell you might be going through.
And I pray, just like Mindy prayed earlier,
I pray it's a moment of a little bit of joy
in the midst of whatever you find yourself
going through in this season.
So the way we'll do this
is we'll just kind of form a line right here,
and we'll start kind of at the front rows
and just work our way back.
We don't do, like, ushers or anything.
You just kind of just feel it out, you know?
And the red is wine, and the white is grape juice,
for those who care about such things.
And we practice what's called an open table,
meaning if you're here tonight
and you want to participate,
then you are free to do that.
You just come forward,
regardless of denomination or, you know, whatever,
or exact theologies, you're free to participate.
So let me invite you to the table.
This is a Celtic Christian invitation.
This is the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come.
You who have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often
and you who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow
and you who have failed.
Come.
Come, because it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites you,
and it's his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Come to the table.
♪ ♪
♪